[Musique]
n
alors c'est exceptionnel qui a lieu ici
à mascara jardin botanique de la réunion
puisque c'est une floraison qu'on attend
depuis six ans la floraison de cette
orchidée qu'on appelle alors à la
plusieurs noms qui correspondent à
plusieurs de ses caractéristiques
le premier nom qu'on peut lui donner ses
orchidées tigre alors orchidées tigre
séville et à la couleur de sa fleur et
donc je vois avec des taches brunes mais
qui fait penser effectivement aux plages
du tigre du félin on l'appelle également
leur kiné géante coup la reine des
orchidées il paraît que c'est l'heure
qu'il est la plus grande la plus haute
du monde
elle peut faire jusqu'à trois mètres de
haut
alors c'est nord qui dès qu'ils nous
vient donc d'asie du sud-est indonésie
malaisie papouasie nouvelle guinée
alors on la trouve là bas au pied des
cascades ça fait rêver
donc c'est la hampe florale qui est
extrêmement grande qui peut contenir
jusqu'à 80 fleurs et les fleurs peuvent
faire jusqu'à 20 cm de circonférence
[Applaudissements]
alors là ça fait deux semaines d'aller
en fleur et la floraison va durer un
mois en profiter c'est une fausse raison
que relativement éphémère la
particularité de cette inflorescences
également c'est qu'elle ne part pas de
la feuille en tout cas de l'aisselle des
feuilles comme c'est qu'habituellement
elle part directement du bulbe est
justement ce bulbe a une particularité
c'est qu'il est très long 1 et ça peut
même parfois faire penser à de la canne
à sucre
on l'appelle également parfois orchidées
canne à sucre voilà donc c'est vraiment
l'orchidée de tous les records qui est à
voir ici à mascara jardin botanique de
la réunion dans une collection intitulée
love collections raffinées fougères mais
qui est vraiment remise à jour avec de
nouvelles variétés à découvrir sur le
site
[Applaudissements]
alors l'objectif de ce jardin c'est de
faire découvrir à tous les publics tous
les trésors du patrimoine végétal de
l'île de la réunion sont des trésors de
nature des espèces indigènes et
endémiques ce sont également des trésors
culturels des espèces patrimoniales donc
faire découvrir ces espèces les montrer
au public également expliquer donc à ce
public quels sont leurs vertus et leurs
usages
leur réputation est donc de partager
justement sur tous les secrets qui
appartiennent à cette salutation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]